[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh it's a great time to welcome our
friend mr wonderful welcome back and
jiren welcome back to the show do you
think that we've seen the bottom and is
or are we headed for another leg down
i have a slightly different view of uh
what is occurring here i've lived
through
many cycles obviously as everybody has
on this call
what i find intriguing about the nature
of this correction if you want to call
it that or the potential of a recession
is that is in the foreshadow and then
the shadow of six
trillion dollars
worth of printing and so
you think about what occurred during the
pandemic which is unprecedented
in any economy's history to take that
much and print it in basically 30 months
and not to expect inflation
well of course that's why we have what
we have right now a 40-year you know new
high in inflation but at the same time
if you could figure out the printing
presses were going to stop
you would be forecasting a new leg up
and here's my thinking on this
there's two bills right now in in front
of uh
congress
and so one is a watered-down version of
build back better they're calling it
anti-inflation which everybody knows is
a joke this is very inflationary but
it's a spend over 10 years so
that's one attribute of more printing
which would maintain an inflationary
stance and of course keep the fed
raising rates which is not good for
equities and then there's this
interesting situation the chip bill
where we're going to spend billions of
dollars it's again free money from a
helicopter
going into the midwest to try and catch
up with what's happened
in our lack of ability to manufacture
semiconductors now
cut it to what it is it means that
management the intel's of the world the
amd's they made a mistake they moved all
their production offshore decades ago
took the us down from 32 percent of
manufacturing down to less than 10. now
they got to bring it home
we're going to print money to make that
happen that also is inflationary and you
can sell it as something as a defense to
the u.s but basically you're supporting
idiot management that's basically what
happened you're picking a sector
taxpayers are not getting
anything from it other than just to give
their tax dollars away to idiot
management and i don't mean
disrespectfully but there's there's
management that can execute and foresees
the future and that's why they're good
managers and there's idiot managers so
you could say many idiot managers guided
manufacturing out and why i bring this
up towards determining the future of the
market is
every midterm election and this starts
in about two weeks okay it's november
8th by midnight november 8th and this is
my thinking as an equity participant and
i i don't think a lot of people think
this through
you've got a situation now where
normally any incumbent you don't have to
get into politics doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what party's in power
they lose seats in the midterm that
happens 100 of the time there's fatigue
people are tired they want to make
changes and it's happening in a regional
level
this time though in my view there's at
least a 50 50 chance that both the house
and the senate flip
to the other party i don't want to get
into politics but the point is
there's a lot of unhappy campers in
america today based on inflation around
food and energy they're really pissed
and so when that happens and it's so
close it's november eight
this is the good news for investors
after that night there will be total
gridlock in washington
for the next two years there will not be
a single piece of legislation passed it
will be impossible to get anything done
and that's a great thing that's a
wonderful thing because markets love
washington gridlock and i think whether
you want to say it's pe expansion or
earnings expansion and it may be both
we're going to continue this leg up now
not 30 percent but if you have an option
between making eight or nine percent
including div distribution and yields on
the s p 500 at a 17 to 18 pe
or getting two to three percent on long
duration treasuries i think that's a
no-brainer you're going to stay long
equities and that's that's my position i
am under weight fixed income big time i
don't care when the fed stops raising
that's another debate do they do 50
basis points do they 75 we're going to
find that out they may do 50. the
narrative has changed to a soft landing
for the first time in decades nobody
gives credit to the fed forever
delivering a soft landing because they
never do
maybe because of the back water of all
this printed cash they have that
opportunity to do this so bottom line is
i make it very clear
bottom is in
we're going to be flatlining for a while
while we wait to see what the fed does
but if we get what i think is going to
happen november 8th
katie bar the doors gridlock in
washington is a wonderful wonderful
thing kevin why is that why why because
i've noticed this in the past as soon as
there's a split senate house all of this
stuff it's suddenly it's good for
equities why because take for example
what's happening right now in this bill
build back better inflation bill they're
adding one percent tax to stock buybacks
why would you do that why would you do
that then they put a 15 minimum
corporate tax in the us an idea floated
by yellen all around the world nobody
followed her now the us is less
competitive the politicians damage bull
markets they've never run businesses
they have no idea what they're doing
they're just throwing this stuff out
there to raise money i don't want to be
a cynic but it's a fact they have no
idea and so they put these crazy
policies in place the more you keep
chipping away with stupid policy the
more damage you do long term to your
economy now this 15 minimum tax does not
help equities it doesn't it's just going
to have companies contort and try and
figure out how to get around it bottom
line the irs 88 000 more agents that's
just going to hassle small businesses in
america not a good thing so bad policy
the whole point is when you have a
situation where washington can move
policy more than 50 percent of it is bad
policy when you have total gridlock they
can't do anything they can't damage
anything listen it's important to have
government for many different services
but not for making economic policy
they're really bad at it so that's why i
point out once you shut down the policy
machine markets get to move back up
i can confirm by the way
because i've done this study going back
to 1850 i think that a gridlock scenario
of some sort is the most bullish outcome
for the markets uh primarily during the
presidential elections but also the
midterms so we want both the house and
the senate to flip that's what that's
what all investors are praying for now
that's what you're saying
it doesn't matter if you just get the
house you're good but you might get both
in which case a new party gets to put
more pro-business policy in place you
know you just don't know but the chance
that the status quo remains after
midnight november 8th i think is zero if
i think of the asset allocation process
right my view is weaker growth my view
is the fed come into play they i they
stop somewhere set or up
i think the bond market rallies what do
you want to own you want to earn the
first furthest out duration thing you
could possibly own which is crypto which
is why crypto based
exactly around the same time as the
market starts picking up that the fed
we're going to pivot so this moment the
euro dollar market starts pricing in
cuts crypto bases so that's how i think
of the portfolio allocation i love bonds
i think nothing well i don't want them
for yield i want them for price
appreciation but the real game in town
is going to be crypto
you want to go the real game in time is
risk
i want to weigh in on the bond
discussion because it's a good one and i
think
in terms of allocation and distribution
of your own portfolio i don't care who
you are there is a place for fixed
income now we run a pretty big um fixed
income desk here we look at all credits
right from treasuries and guppies all
the way over to factoring for retailers
and the the challenge we're having right
now in pricing in risk is in a bond
situation if you get it wrong you have
to wait a decade to get your principal
back that's not a good outcome and you
could go shorter duration but what's
bothering me as a bond guy that's how i
started my career is what blackrock is
doing right now instead of buying fixed
income and remember they're trying to
put to work billions every week
they're buying us apartment buildings
instead they're reallocating away from
an actual bond a covenant instrument and
they're buying fixed income based on
distributions of rent
because they're
not a good sign
i'm just after capital gains you know
where are bonds in a year's time
probably at one percent okay in terms of
yield so capital gain is my trade for
yield forget about it they these guys
have so many pension liabilities
uh or
hurdles that as you say they have to do
that and we'll come into the east yield
later because it's super interesting for
these guys as well but you're dead right
i mean bonds really have no value even
in a pension fund because it'll never
close the funding gap ever
at three percent yeah they have to just
the average distribution from a pension
is about 5.7 percent they have to send
it every year you can't get that from
any form of fixed income without taking
huge risk on leverage or duration and so
i i think i get your capital gain play
you're making a call on interest rates
and i would tend to think you're going
to be right in the next 24 months but as
an investor who's got to kind of put
capital to work every day i'm having a
real hard time on fixed income here
because if my bogeys call it six percent
and i'm only getting 300 basis points
from a portfolio fixed income i'm
offside 300 basis points on money
you only want to rent fixed income you
don't want to own it if you know what i
mean it's like it's fine for a trade
for a but it's not something you want to
marry because you're just going to lose
money and there's an analogy to the 40s
and 50s here especially in the 40s where
i mean the fed is not doing yield curve
control at least not yet maybe it will
uh at some point but you know that once
the inflation rate on a structural basis
let's say a five-year keger of the cpi
crossed over the 10-year yield you had a
decade and a half of negative real
returns and you know if you hold a bond
to maturity as we all know the yield on
that bond is your return right if you
hold it so a ten year at two and three
quarters that's going to be your nominal
return and if inflation is at four which
is not a prediction but then you have a
negative return so i'd rather even just
buy like utility stocks you know which
which uh if you between the dividend of
three percent and and earnings growth or
maybe some buybacks you can get you know
high single digits
back to the 40s as you and i talked
about several times is there was a
period where it traded sideways
and then equities went up 900
because of negative real rates i look at
the trend of nega of five year real
rates since 2000 they're just trending
lower the average if you draw a nice
average line on it is negative one
percent we got to plus 50 basis points
and broke the economy i mean we're
[ __ ] i mean there's no way we can hold
have positive real rates in this economy
so the reality is i think negative one
percent real rates as you said which is
fantastic for equities terrible for
fixed income investors
i think for crypto djinns i think uh
bonds is a non-starter i've got to be
i've got to be really honest and this
channel is full of digits i think fixed
income is probably the furthest away
they want to be it's either going to be
it's either going to be tesla stocks and
and meme stocks or it's going to be
crypto speaking of blackrock allocating
funds they made two announcements this
week the first announcement is that they
partnered up with coinbase to bring
crypto trading into their aladdin system
um and to make it easy to buy and store
crypto and then they made a second
announcement that they've started a
bitcoin private trust which allows their
investors to invest directly into
bitcoin so two announcements in the span
of i guess a week
how big is this news around aladdin and
allowing their investment base to to be
deployed i think you missed a third
announcement a third announcement from
blackrock and fidelity simultaneously
they each put 200 million dollars of
equity
into circle in the f round at a 9
billion valuation less a discount they
got which i'm going to assume is 15
that is huge remember this is a very
controversial asset class stable coins
are a [ __ ] show right now and there you
have the largest most conservative
completely compliant institutions on
earth putting 400 million dollars now i
have to disclose okay i participated in
that round i saw that happening so i
i'm i'm in that round i own a piece of
circle now on the f round beside
fidelity and blackrock and i did it
because i saw them going into it i would
have never done that without the
endorsement of such compliant
sec regulated entities making a bet
in the middle of a shitstorm on stable
coins it's a turning point for crypto
that's what i think
so the turning point is the three pieces
of news put together just to get it all
right
no it's not just that we're going to get
regulation listen we were supposed to
get a policy just on stable coins
reviewed this month they pushed it and
i'm talking about now on the hill in
washington they pushed it to september
to consider it you got to remember
there's hagerty there's loomis there's
toomey and and toomey is going to retire
in january he wants to get one piece of
policy done he wants to get stable coins
regulated and the policy they're putting
forward i've been spending a lot of my
time in washington on these bills and
i'm not the only guy doing this and i'm
totally transparent on my interests here
i want to get some kind of payment
system for my global businesses when
we're transferring cash i want to use
usdc between here and geneva we index i
have an indexing business so we're
constantly every day taking u.s dollars
aching it over to zurich they charge me
a fortune for that it takes 36 hours
sometimes then they nip me on the fx
trade when i go into swiss francs and
buy a nestle or roche whatever i'm
buying to index it and then they screw
me again on the way out i could
completely eliminate that with a payment
system and everybody knows that so
there's a lot of utility second reason
you got to be bullish here is this
both sides are supporting this dems and
republicans because it makes the dollar
if you get a u.s stable coin policy in
place it makes it the default payment
system of the earth not the swiss franc
not the euro not the british pound not
the chinese one the us dollar so this is
coming back to the house on the floor in
september
and it may be the first piece of
legislation that provides the launch
ramp for more crypto policy now you know
there's a war going on between the sec
and the other regulators a turf war on
crypto but you can't deny crypto is here
to stay in fact i believe in the next 10
years it'll be the 12th sector the s p
and i'm trying to make bets all through
the continuum of projects i own
everything i have 32 positions i don't
know which ones are going to work i
don't need them all to work i just need
a few huge position ethereum huge in
bitcoin solana polygon helium
pollen the new one i just took on
there's all kinds of projects and the
thinking for me is this you go teach a
class of mit graduates in engineering
right now i do guest lecturing there one
third of the class are entrepreneurial
where do they want to go they have no
interest in working in any of the 11
sectors of the economy they want to work
on the blockchain they want to be in
crypto you can't pour that much elect
intellectual capital into something and
not have great outcomes one day it's
like being in the beginning of the
internet and i'm talking about the
smartest brightest men and women from
around the world say
screw everything else i want to work on
crypto i don't even look at the bitcoin
price anymore it's eth
me too
it's a good segue but you've got to
remember we've been talking about the
merge for five years
okay
you know
um
let me be the skeptic this is my largest
position right now ethan's moved up and
put it at the top of the heap of my 32
positions
i i'm a skeptic until i see it happen
because you got to think about who loses
in the merge you know and and if you're
if you're a minor right now you're not
loving this merge idea and there's a lot
of capital tied up in that and so
when it happens i'll believe it but we
have seen this thing punted down the
road five times so what makes you so
confident it's going to happen
okay so let's let's quickly talk about
that so yesterday they moved on to the
last of the test nets which is called
the gurley test net that was a
successful move so pretty much they've
gone on all the test nets and
everything's worked which kind of means
that in practice in theory everything
works now i agree with you that the
miners have got a lot to lose and that's
why the miners are now forming this
coalition to actually fork ethereum so
what you're going to get is you're going
to get an eth proof of work and you're
going to get an eth proof of stake chain
and that's currently what's happening
okay so i'm not sure that that's a good
thing but what we know for sure let me
just give you the facts so right now
there's a derivative of the proof of
work ethereum which is trading at 3.8
percent of the value of the
proof-of-stake ethereum
so what people are
are forecasting is that the chain will
split
you'll get a proof of work ethereum and
a proof of stake ethereum and 96 percent
of the value will lie in the proof of
stake ethereum and 3.8 the value will
align the proof of stakeholder
now circle usdc usdt and a whole lot of
others have all said that they're going
to support the proof of stake check
because you can't support both because
you kind of get your coins on both
but yet there is
four percent value in the proof of work
chain uh earlier this week that was
eight percent so
the value of the proof of work chain is
coming down
um
look right now the futures are pricing
the merge to actually happen and
actually happen on time which is quite
ironic because anyone who's been around
for any amount of time always knows that
ethereum is is delayed on things
but i mean these are the facts right now
this is what the market's talking about
right now
some of this is is causing havoc in
capital markets around data centers
i want to point something out here that
i think we haven't touched on uh and
again i'm tracking this from indexers so
if
one of my core businesses is to index
for sovereign wealth seventy percent of
capital that's invested around the world
and it may be when we measure it again
75 percent is in sovereign wealth and
pension and so i can report to you
faithfully that they own no crypto zero
and so all for all the excitement and
the reason they don't is they don't have
any infrastructure to be compliant it's
not just that they're not allowed to
because it's not regulated they have no
infrastructure to mark to market and so
that their compliance departments can
monitor whether they're over levered
whether they have whatever their
mandates are let's say you're maxed out
at a name at five percent they don't
have any infrastructure to make that
work like a stock or bond they're
working on that so is ftx so is finances
all the although major trading platforms
are trying to provide that
infrastructure but as it stands right
now
last year up to just before the the
correction they were using public
bitcoin miners in the us as a proxy to
own bitcoin because it was a it traded
in direct correlation a bas and i know
that because i indexed for them and so
i i'll never forget this this is crazy i
we were
you know we were indexing other indexes
are doing the same thing the indexing
business is about making three basis
points so you know if you're an oil-rich
country and you're you're bringing in
500 million us dollars a day the only
place you can put it is the s p 500 you
don't move the market with you know that
and so
at the end of the day they say okay
index to s p x oil x airlines because
most of those countries own their own
airlines so and they don't want any oil
because they got plenty of oil so
when it came to bitcoin they said look
we want 50 basis points come up with an
indice that is a proxy to to the risk on
on bitcoin bitcoin's the only one they
care about and so everybody designed
these indexes now the morning the sec
memo came out
calling for auditors to sign the carbon
credit claims in other words if you're a
s p 500 company and you say look i'm
carbon neutral because i buy carbon
offsets
well the sec wants you to sign that
because everybody knows carbon offsets
are [ __ ] and if you're if you're a
polluter and you say you own an acre of
the amazon that's bs now why would that
matter to bitcoin here's what happened
within minutes everybody was an extra
got a phone call from sovereign wealth
saying dump every public mining stock in
bitcoin you've got because none of them
are going to be able to pass this audit
it's never going to work and they are
agnostic to price we were selling into
the clients of 20 an hour and i didn't
want to do that but we did it you go
look at a chart of a marathon or a hot
aid or a hive
that was the indexers dumping those
stocks and now
there's no way they're going to give a
proxy for bitcoin because half the world
won't buy them because they're polluters
they're dirty miners so now you have to
do mining with hydro or you have to do
money with nuclear power and the biggest
investors in those facilities like the
one in norway there's a company called
bit zero private is the uae same with
north dakota the burgham announcement
last week that old nuclear facility
that's been on the market since 1975
just got sold to bid zero to turn it
into a giant clean data center so new
money moving into it which i say is
bullish for bitcoin because at the end
of the day the highest return when
you're stabilizing a giant 600 million
dollar data center before you sell it to
microsoft is you rent it to bitcoin
miners so you've got these massive
facilities being built another indice
which i think is a foreshadow of demand
because when we get policy on bitcoin
and it gets indexed to one percent in a
900 billion dollar fund that's really
good towards getting that price up to a
hundred thousand that's the only way
you're going to get it because if
there's volatility you've always got the
underlying bid from the sovereign wealth
fund you have to be bullish if you
believe in regulation that's my point
let's talk about the eth because i think
aral you touched on the ethnic um
huge implications for me if i mean if i
think about it logically if the merge is
successful and look right now all the
test nets have been successful
you've now got yourself the opposite of
bitcoin you've got yourself an esg
friendly asset because it's now moved
from proof of work to proof-of-stake
you've got an asset that is now truly
deflationary because remember rewards
are cut by 99
and there's eip1559 which actually burns
ethereum so net net you are decreasing
on your ethereum
and you've got a high yielding asset
which bitcoin is not
so remember institutions who are looking
for yield can now go into ethereum and
get you get themselves
real yield and when i say real real
yield it's the reward for validating on
the network it's not
it's it's a proof-of-stake validator
reward
so you've got yourself
dare i say a better asset for
institutional investing
so look all of those points are correct
and no get policy will they get somebody
in washington to say that's okay
if you're a public pension plan they
need the policy on on crypto in the
sense even if they only regulate bitcoin
and ethereum and so many people in the
crypto world are against regulation but
i say that's false if you get regulation
you get more capital you've made a great
case right there for why we want policy
on ethereum do you see ethereum flipping
bitcoin at some point and i'm gonna say
at some point
without question
you're i'm having a hard time with that
because
when i talk to sovereign wealth i don't
care if it's norway or the uae or saudi
they want bitcoin they have not got to
the analysis that we've just gone
through they want the proxy uh of
bitcoin
uh and they want that volatility i think
i think for financial services i agree
that eth the gas fees are a joke that's
the problem
this will help solve for it but if that
becomes the default
platform for other digital assets that
will help but in the immediate term
the demand is for one to three percent
of a portfolio a standard these these
these sovereign wealth portfolios look
like this no more than twenty percent
any one sector no more than five percent
any one name so you're never gonna find
you know boeing or bank of america more
than five percent the 900 billion dollar
fund all the indexers know that it's a
really standard format
when you ask them if you could buy a
digital asset which one would it be and
what allocation it's about 50 basis
points on the low end up to 300 basis
points on the high end and 99 of the
time they say bitcoin that's all they
know and so it's going to take a while
for that demand to come and i think it
would be number two and they certainly
like usdc and they love solana and polly
you go down the list by some market cap
i get it but right now if we had policy
on bitcoin
i swear to you the price of the price
would be sixty thousand dollars in two
weeks and kevin what um if you index
like bitwise is doing a bunch a basket
of crypto
let's assume they're not ready as you
say but let's when they come in
they're gonna want that kind of product
right because then that gives them
because we don't know like you
we've all got a bunch of positions we
don't know what's actually going to win
here or not we could all have opinions
but it means nothing until we we find
out but
surely there's going to be big demand
for index products in this space at some
point
except the really big guys do their own
index they basically they they rent
indexers like me and they say design
this because most often those commercial
products are doing 20 basis points to 45
basis points they're never going to pay
that you're lucky to get two basis
points out of them and so that you do
the work and then they have a custodial
and that's where it gets interesting
because bitcoin trades 24 hours a day
and all the all of the crypto does and
that's a new beast for the compliance
departments of these giant funds but the
demand
i mean
the reason i'm long now with all this
volatility we have 20 of our operating
companies assets that's our max
in crypto across 32 positions i'm about
to add pollen which is a decentralized
telco we've done a lot of research on we
like it
we think there's a lot of interest there
but that's a really fringe project the
point is i'm trying to get ahead of the
day because we're all agreeing that at
some point we're going to get policy i
need to be long before that happens
because
that's the reward you're going to get is
when that stuff gets indexed and i
whoever gets to index it the demand for
at least bitcoin and ethereum in the out
of the beginning is insatiable it is
insatiable at the sovereign and pension
level and for all the skeptics that that
are you know don't like crypto
they're going to watch that asset move
into an indexed price which i think is
60 000. i have a quick question for you
on this
what regulations do they need do they
need uae regulation because dubai is
doing a pretty good job saudi's doing a
pretty good job now or do they need
global regulation what what regulation
framework
does norway need does you know in
general
so
the adgm which is the uh
let's talk about the uae because this is
a fantastic question
last month i got my uae citizenship and
i did that to go through the scrutiny of
the background checking so i could act
as an operator and an indexer in that
market and and a financial services
entity and so that was a lot of work and
it was worth it i've been trying for
three years and they don't grant many of
them
so the
when you look at uae
it's abu dhabi is 95 percent of the
capital so you have to operate out of
there it's called the adgm
and they set policy on crypto they grant
licenses for exchanges but here's the
thing that they won't do they will not
let's call it
jump hop the sec they will not do this
and make it a standard for their own
sovereign wealth before the sec gets a
chance to move and the reason for that
is really political in nature the
largest manager of sovereign wealth in
the world is blackrock that's larry fink
he's not going to do this until he gets
the go-ahead from the sec and so they're
not going to ever mess around with their
largest manager and larry's telling them
and i'm speculating this okay i don't
know this for certainty but he's saying
let's just wait because when we get the
sec to approve this whatever approval it
is and we'll build you the
infrastructure so you can mark to market
it so that you're staying compliant in
your mandates
then they're going to put on their
waiting and so
i think this thing is going to happen
after the midterms after we get the
policy unstable they're going to start
looking at bitcoin i don't know which
regulator is going to get to regulate it
because there's a turf war going on but
you if you're a speculator and an
investor like the three of us are
looking at this and and you both of you
guys are so down the rabbit hole as i am
i need to be there ahead of this
decision because it'll happen quickly
and you won't get be able to put on your
position and that the market will move
against you so fast i am extremely
optimistic uh on bitcoin and ethereum
over the next call of 24 months and the
way you should measure your enthusiasm
or curb it maybe is they struck down the
bitcoin etf just weeks ago even though
the canadians have one and i believe
that the osc which regulates the
canadian etf of ethereum which is marked
to market real bitcoin each day okay
they basically are the petri dish for
the sec they work so close together in
canada for example you know how coinbase
is at war with the regulator right now
there's a company called wonderful with
700 000 accounts 720 000 accounts
regulated by the osc canadians are
allowed to trade 14 different tokens
legitimately regulated with the
authorities being tax reported they're
so advanced and we haven't even got
there yet stateside and so i think
they're using canada uae is talking to
the osc why do i know that because i own
that company and i show them the order
from the osc and i went to abu dhabi and
sat down with the ad gm and said why
can't we use the canadian order and
build it here
and they are thinking about it but i
know they're hesitating because the fab
bank is the largest bank in the uae they
want the central bank to regulate i mean
we're getting down the rabbit hole here
but final question then kevin the the
question everyone want to know
what's when do you think
best guess you've got no idea best guess
we'd get the clarity scc cftc
and
yes no
by second quarter 2023 after the
midterms if the house flips you get the
republicans on this they're more they're
way more pro-crypto most of the bill
initiatives are coming out of red states
and i don't want to be political but if
you get the house flipping they'll put
that on the agenda but don't expect
every token to be regulated they're
going to focus on the market
capitalization and say here's policy on
bitcoin here's policy policy on eth
i think you want to be long
after november 8th i mean this is
everybody's got to speculate on what to
do here but you've seen
the winter at the bottoms we're slowly
crawling out of the toilet here
your portfolios are up you know 20 in
some cases 23
i mean our 20 position went down to 15.2
that's pain that's pain my friends and
our desk was saying what do we do what
do we do i said we do nothing where we
know we're in this this volatile asset
class and we're going to have to wait
for some policy that's why whenever i
talk about crypto now i'm pro-regulation
i want the sovereigns
backing me up with a bid every night
guys we do have like two more minutes
and i do want to ask you a question and
it's not a bullish question and that's
around the u.s sanctioning an an open
source protocol in tornado cash this
week uh admittedly as per chain analysis
about 10 of the activity of this
protocol is for hacks and thefts and 90
of it is actually for legitimate privacy
transactions
i i say this is good thing for the
market scraping the patina off the bad
actors the idiot managers the over
leveraged unsophisticated traders it's
important to do that because it makes
the rest of this ecosphere very very
stable and the more you get
i love it when these these guys using
leverage who've never done this before
i'm assuming because they blew their
brains out the old-fashioned way they're
eliminated from the market the lawyers
will pick over the carcasses in
litigation that's okay but these players
are out of the market and that's
important the dna of the remaining
survivors gets better that's my whole
point so
you know any these these crazy the luna
story this story get rid of all that
crap because i can tell you right now
algorithmic based stable coins are not
going to be popular in the market you
can't wipe out 50 60 billion dollars and
get everybody back on board that's not
easy to do so i think that's a good
thing i'm pro
on this thing and i just want to i want
to scrape out the idiot management more
scraping of idiot managers it's better
for the for those managers that remain
and survive
if you like that video wait you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe